[Music]
what do you talk to your kids about like
what's the hardest thing about having
teenagers these days besides the texting
oh you talk to you first you try to get
their attention that's hard they're on
the phone all the time right I try to
talk to them about the birds and the
bees but they they know all about what
are you gonna yeah how old are they 17
yeah you know you have a birds and bees
discussion at that age that's that's a
older age to have the bird first of all
no one calls it the birds and bees
especially wait a minute what do you
call it what do you talk to your kids
about what do you do Conan the
Magnificent Conan Conan the great what
are you talk to you did you not come
here to be humiliated I how do you
handle it well first of all it hasn't I
let my wife do it okay my wife talks
them about those matters and she's
largely responsible for raising them I
live here in the studio
I'm tired of I think my wife is very
good she's raised - good boy she has
most to do with their their success I
mean I I try to be good for I'm a
spoiler I I'm not strict I don't I'm not
you just wanted to have a good time yeah
yeah and they're different so kids when
I was a kid I never saw a $20 bill I was
very poor
right these kids got 100 we've won 400
I'm gonna go see so I think I mean
that's our son Sylvester Stallone
so just curious you talked about when
you were a kid when did when did you get
the birds Envy did you get a birds and
bees discussion no I did not my father
died when I was nine and a half and
right a mother never discussed it with
me
so you figured it out on your own I
figured how did you do it I had about
two years ago your kids explained it we
all figured out right Annie
yeah from a book at the library yeah
well we're all here
everyone's a product of it right right
you all know what we're talking about
but it's okay yeah how long as long as
your raise them to be good yeah raise
your kids to do good my point pinion I
don't know I've never seen you like this
jabbing at me I don't know what you got
to do but what you're about to leave
this earth I'll second
my last work she'll teach em ghetto
you